moi je parle d'identité risme parce que
l'identité c'est pas quelque chose que
mauvais en soi et donc j'ai cherché un
terme qui indique une sorte de
pathologie de l'identité c'est le fait
de réduire les personnes ou les groupes
à des entités principales fixe homogène
qui est deux qui auquel sont réduits les
personnes et les groupes concernés 1 est
donc cette identité risme il a des
formes extrêmement diverse et il est
dans les formes disons classique du
nationalisme d'extrême droite mais on
trouve un renouveau d'une pensée de
l'appartenance et de l'appartenance
nationale notamment chez frédéric lordon
qui situe dans la gauche radicale
on le trouve du côté de la gauche dite
républicaine avec des gens comme laurent
bouvet ou jacques julliard est donc
cette prégnance de l'identité et on le
trouve dans des mouvements
contestataires que j'utilise beaucoup
comme les indigènes de la république
houria bouteldja qui développe ce que
j'appelle une forme d'identité risme
inversée et donc cette prégnance de la
fixation identitaire dans le débat
public est relativement récent elle
vient au départ de l'extrême droite
c'est pour ça que se crée des
interférences entre des formes d'extrême
droite des formes de droite classique
des formes de gauche modérée des formes
de gauche radicale et elle nous oblige à
penser autrement l'émancipation
il me semble que cette fixation
identitaire elles nous obligent au
contraire à penser l'émancipation qui a
souvent été pensée sous l'angle de
l'autonomie individuelle et collective
de dison de kant jusqu'à castoriadis
comme aussi quelque chose qui renvoie à
la bouille à l'ouverture identitaire à
l'ouverture de lettres et c'est pour ça
que des figures importantes pour moi
pour repenser l'émancipation aujourd'hui
sont d'abord emmanuel levinas dans sa
pensée de la singularité d'autrui est
aussi un penseur comme edouard glissant
dans sa vision de
de la créolisation
[Musique]